when you first learn math you see things
like two
plus three
is equal to five
or you might see six
plus one is equal
to seven
or you might see 8
minus 2 is equal to 6
and all of these you might think that
the equal sign just says hey give me the
answer figure out what 2 plus 3 is 2
plus three well the answer is five six
plus one the answer is seven eight minus
two the answer is six
that's not quite right what the equal
sign is saying is that what's on
the left side
is the same amount the same quantity as
what is on the right hand side it's
saying that two plus three is the same
thing as five and you didn't have to
write it this way you could have written
you could have written five is equal to
two plus three
you could write that three
plus two
is equal to two plus three notice here
we're not figuring out the answer we're
just saying that whatever three plus two
is that's going to be the same thing as
whatever two plus three is we know that
they both equal five you could even mix
addition and subtraction you could write
you could write that six plus one is the
same thing is equal to
eight
minus one
they are the same amount the same
quantity what is six plus one well
that's seven what's eight minus one well
that is 7. so the equal sign does not
mean just give me the answer or just you
know add the numbers or subtract the
numbers an equal sign
is saying that's what what's on the
left-hand side is the same amount as
what's on the right hand side
so with that in our brain let's write
some statements using equal signs some
equations you could even say using equal
signs and figure out which of them are
actually true
so if i were to write down
if i were to write down
i won't even read it out because it
might give it away if i were to write
down this
is this true
well the number on the left here is 18.
the number on the left is 18. the number
on the on the right is a different
number it is 81.
it is 81. they swap or we swapped the 1
and the 8. they're in different places
this is a different number this is 81
these are not equal
these are not
not equal so this statement is not true
and sometimes you might even see someone
do something like this that means not
equal 18 is not equal to 81.
let's keep going
what if i were to write
minus 3
plus
minus 0
is
equal to
is equal to
zero
plus one minus one plus
eight
is this true
well let's figure out what the left hand
side is
see 9 minus 3 is 6 plus 2 is 8 minus 0
is 8.
so this
this if i were to if i were to compute
it that's equal to eight
and then on the right hand side i have
zero plus one minus one well one minus
one is zero so this is all going to be
eight
so this is
this is true eight equals eight this is
another way of writing eight nine minus
three plus two minus zero this is eight
and this is also eight so once again the
equal sign is just saying that this what
we have on the left is the same as what
we have on the right
let's do another example
let's do another example let's do two
more examples if i were to write
this
is this true
well you might be tempted hey if i put a
one and a zero together it's going to
look like a 10 but that's not this is
not how we do mathematics this is not
how we add things 1 plus 0 is just 1. so
this would be the same thing as saying
that 10 is equal to 1 which we know is
not true so this is not equal this is
not equal let's do one more
let's say i had seven
plus one
is equal to three
plus four
is this equation true well what do we
have on the left seven plus one is eight
three plus four is seven these are not
the same quantity they're not the same
amount so these are not
equal
and we're done